ah the most holy of holidays st. Patty's
Day if you're Irish March seventeenth
might have some real meaning for you and
your heritage and if you're not it means
you're going to wear green and go drink
beer no shame any excuse for a raucous
workday happy hour is fine by us and
these apps are also happy to assist
first if beer is what you're after
download untapped it's like Instagram
meets Yelp for beer tons of pretty foamy
pictures with ratings and information
the app can tell you what's on tap
nearby and you can even gamma phi the
whole thing by earning badges for your
pints next up it would be irresponsible
to tell you about all the spoons without
talking about abv it's an app that tells
you exactly how much alcohol is in
whatever beard is your drinking maybe
three of those nine percent stouts is
enough wouldn't you say and I'm assuming
you already have lift or uber installed
per what numbers you're seeing on abv
maybe order one of those lastly in case
you forgot there's a cultural element to
st. Patrick's Day so maybe put down the
beer and download Irish Gaelic by Nemo a
hands-free language app that helps you
learn common words and phrases and then
you can use it to order a beer and say
cheers and Gaelic slowly to see how we
came full circle there
you